let me pick up on our caller from the
three one five area code who's been
holding for a while caller from three
one five what's your name where you
calling from
yes hi David can you hear me yes I can
yeah I love that bit I was trying to
think of doing a Scottish accident to
try to fool you but I don't have good
acting skills there hi my name is
Tristan I'm calling you from a New York
number but I'm currently in Oregon right
now got it and I have a question I have
a question about disabled people because
I feel like this kind of reads into a
broader issue about disabled people
being left out of the conversation
within mainstream and quite honestly
independent media as well okay because
you know right now during this virus
disabled people are really suffering
significantly I was just on an
organizing call this Monday people were
talking about you know how difficult it
was to you know get essential services
that they need for example I'm blind I
can't see so you know when I'm you know
and I need to get groceries sometimes I
have them delivered but you know I'm
looking at delivery times and they're
just like way backed up extremely really
high demand right so I think it's really
important you know to to consider
disabled people in this conversation
that we're having about essential
services I completely agree with you
now how do you what what grocery
delivery service do you typically use I
typically used into the cart sometimes I
use Walmart and what kind of an
interface do you use to navigate the
website um so I have an iPhone and as of
like 2009 iPhones have built-in
technology called screen readers right
and what that does that takes the text
and that turns it into speech so that I
can understand it so let me ask you a
question about that because I've seen
that technology if you're on a website
like if I go to the Amazon fresh website
and I'm trying to do a grocery delivery
order the screen is
with stuff like will the screenreader
actually read to you the fact that
there's before I even get to the
delivery time on the page it says like
you know books customer service contact
us like there's all this extraneous
stuff that has nothing to do with me
trying to order groceries does the
screen reader read every single one of
those words before it gets to the
relevant stuff not always so like you
can there are shortcuts there are
technical shortcuts like you can go by
heading you can go by linking people by
landmark you know all different web
elements are organized in a way
sometimes people have a harder time
utilizing it just because it's it can be
kind of complex especially for like
older blind individuals who don't
necessarily have the technological
skills that yeah you know the 25-year
old guy like me has and let me just one
other thing about and I hope I hope this
is OK you asked so when the delivery
shows up what is the process like how do
how do you know that it's your instacart
delivery I'm so like you know I will
usually get a call or a text message and
that reads it to me as well so like you
know it'll say messages notification
so-and-so is trying to get a hold of you
your instacart deliveries here got it
got it yeah so Wow how much we take are
granted right how much we take for
granted when we when we don't have
something like that going on in our
lives
well yeah indeed I think it's really
really really important that we talk
about this there's a Twitter hashtag we
are essential that where people can kind
of submit their stories and tell people
what what things are going on I mean
this is a really serious serious matter
and this is the first time I've ever
called into a show like yours blood and
I really appreciate the work that you do
you know I really think she ate the word
do you do I know you
what's the what would you say is the
most difficult thing for you as a blind
person day-to-day that might not be on
the radar of people with bigger honestly
people's ignorance is really difficult
to deal with you know when you're you
know when you're in a big city trying to
like navigate the world I'm a college
graduate and so
you know when you're in a big city
trying to navigate the world people just
have all these different opinions of
where you should be how you should be
acting and don't really understand
really the things that you know the
technological advances that we have and
that really helped me a lot and can you
know provide a bunch of opportunities
for blind individuals to navigate the
world so I think that's the biggest
thing to overcome
understood Tristan Tristan listen I
really appreciate your call yeah thank
you for taking it all right Tristan from
Oregon very good to hear from him okay
let's check in with our caller from the
5/1 area code who's calling - hi David
this is Annie
hey Annie what's going on thank you for
being such a steadfast beacon of hope
for all of us and holding up for us all
and I I feel Bernie's been slighted and
undermined on so many levels and I feel
that how the election was run in
Wisconsin is in my mind criminal what do
you thought well so I have two thoughts
about that I mean listen Bernie lost by
a lot Bernie lost by more than two
million votes maybe 2.5 million votes to
Joe Biden
it wasn't close and I think it's
important to understand that in any
analysis that we make now as far as the
Wisconsin stuff there have been people
saying you know and it's pretend
particularly moot now that Bernie has
dropped out but a lot of people have
said it was Bernie's responsibility to
drop out so that Wisconsin wouldn't vote
on Tuesday that's not true at all there
were local elections there was a
judgeship on the ballot it's not just
Bernie who needed to drop out in order
to stop the Wisconsin election there was
other stuff on the ballot so I think
that criticism of Bernie is completely
unfair very anything else I'm not an e
no just wanted to get that question all
right thanks Andy great to hear from you
Annie from I believe from Wisconsin
based on based on the area code